Avengers end game gave fans everything
they were hoping for well almost
everything
to the surprise of many Marvel decided
to do away with the time-honored
tradition and didn't include any mid or
post credits scenes in endgame here are
the reasons why spoilers ahead as you're
no doubt aware a spider-man homecoming
sequel is right around the corner
someone nice to finally meet you
inspiring me Marvel President Kevin
Feige has confirmed that spider-man far
from home
takes place shortly after the events of
Avengers and game producer Amy Pascal
went one step further revealing that the
highly anticipated Spidey sequel is
kicking off just minutes after the
fourth Avengers flick seeing a
spider-man far from home is officially
the end of phase 3 it sounds like Marvel
is saving a huge phase for post-credit
reveal for that movie as Feige told
comic book calm there's a tremendous
amount of potential and the tremendous
amount of additional characters and
storylines and groups of characters that
were going to keep playing with if we're
lucky we'll get our first proper glimpse
at these new characters drawing the
closing credits for spider-man far from
home and the game is shaping up to be
the end of an era and the death of more
than one original Avenger makes it the
heaviest Marvel movie to date the studio
clearly wanted viewers to take in the
three-hour movie before they began
looking forward to what's coming next
as the Verge's home garden burger out
with endgame it's time to pay the check
and then the story instead of endlessly
escalating and teasing the next thing
well there was no post-credit scene to
speak of Marvel didn't leave us totally
hanging fans who were willing to sit
through the lengthy credits were
rewarded with a little surprise a huge
Marvel logo and the clanking sound
[Music]
sure this probably left a lot of viewers
scratching their heads of fans who have
been with the MCU from the very
beginning quickly recognize the sound
[Music]
as if to reinforce the idea that every
film we'd seen was building up to this
film Marvel decided to make the final
moment and the credits at nod to the
Marvel movie that started at all
2008 Iron Man it's the sound of Tony
Stark cobbling together as Iron Man
shell from the first Iron Man
well lens game was clearly something of
a swan song for some of the original
Avengers the man of the hour was Tony
Stark
he started it all in that cave and he
ended it when he snapped Thanos and his
army out of existence
there's been plenty of news regarding
the future of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe post phase 3 with Marvel
President Kevin Feige having discussed a
number of projects that the studio
currently has in the pipeline
Feige has suggested the Eternals will
play a big role in the plot going
forward he's also revealed that an
appearance from Miss Marvel otherwise
known as Pakistani American teen Kamala
Khan is a distinct possibility in the
near future why he told the BBC the
character is definitely sort of in the
works the producer has been purposefully
vague as far as details are concerned
and for very good reason the fact of the
matter is phase 4 is still very much up
in the air with that in mind creating a
post-credits scene for avengers end game
would have been especially tricky guess
we'll just have to wait and see what the
future has in store as a wise man once
said sometimes patience is the key to
victory sometimes it leads to very
little that's very true as for what
phase 4 has in store guess we'll just
have to patiently wait until spider-man
far from home hits theaters on July 5th
2019 you don't want any part of it check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about
Avengers endgame are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]